this place is an attempt to permanently
install stuff that's difficult to move
around and create a living environment
of kinetic sculptures hey this is the
Trabant it's a three motor kinetic
sculpture with lots of different
lighting elements on it it's based on
the the tilt awhirl or sometimes called
true bent a an amusement park ride and
it's got three axes two rotary axes plus
a tilt axis in between and it has 3 DC
gear motors that power the three axes I
wanted to create things that had
physical movement fully custom
mechanical objects with electronics take
a long time three months to two years in
the case this is slave one it's a upper
body human range of motion and human
speed robot my objects are more
traditional mechanical engineering based
so they use machined metal and machined
plastic bearings motors then there are
some additional elements like the shells
on this piece or rolled metal I do all
the machining it's all from scratch